Générique
- Kathia Gilder: Bonjour à tous.
26 minutes pour revoir le meilleur
de l'actualité à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat.
- Alexandre Poussart: On accueille
Rachid Temal, sénateur du
Val-d'Oise et président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat.
- Kathia Gilder: Marlène Schiappa
face aux sénateurs de la
commission d'enquête sur le Fonds
Marianne.
La ministre a tenté de justifier
l'utilisation de ce fonds créé
après l'assassinat de Samuel Paty.
Mohamed Sifaoui était lui aussi
auditionné.
L'Assemblée nationale ne touche
pas à la liberté d'installation
des médecins.
L'amendement transpartisan qui
prévoyait de réguler l'offre sur
le territoire a été rejeté.
Il avait été déposé dans le cadre
d'une proposition de loi de la
majorité pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux.
On parlera avec notre invité de la
loi de programmation militaire, en
discussion au Sénat.
Une loi qui prévoit 413 milliards
d'euros pour permettre la défense
et aux armées de faire face aux
nouvelles menaces.
- Alexandre Poussart: La
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur
le Fonds Marianne a mené des
auditions cruciales pour mieux
comprendre cette affaire.
Marlène Schiappa a essayé de
minimiser sa responsabilité dans
les dysfonctionnements de la
gestion de ce fonds censé lutter
contre la radicalisation.
Mohamed Sifaoui, qui a dirigé
l'une des associations mises en
cause, s'est défendu de tout
détournement de fonds publics.
- C'était la dernière audition et
sans doute l'une des plus
attendues des sénateurs.
Dans une ambiance tendue, la
commission d'enquête sur le Fonds
Marianne a interrogé Mohamed
Sifaoui.
- Je pense que vous devez garder
vos nerfs et votre maîtrise.
- Je suis quelqu'un d'assez
entier.
Dès le moment où on ne me respecte
plus, je vais aller sur un autre
ton.
- L'essayiste était responsable
éditorial de la principale
association bénéficiaire du Fonds
Marianne avec 355.000 euros.
Il a admis devant les sénateurs
avoir bénéficié en plus d'un
contrat de consultant issu de
l'organe chargé de distribuer les
crédits du fonds.
Une double rémunération qui
interroge.
Marlène Schiappa l'aurait
encouragé à déposer un dossier.
- Quand un ministre sort pour vous
saluer et pour vous dire qu'il
compte sur vous, est-ce que c'est
encourager à mettre en application
un projet ou pas?
Les conseillers de la ministre
vous disent que la ministre
apprécie énormément votre projet,
qu'elle croit en votre projet...
- Mais la ministre dément cette
version.
Elle a démenti tout lien avec
Mohamed Sifaoui et elle a renvoyé
la responsabilité de l'attribution
des crédits à son cabinet et la
ministre assure être en charge du
dossier.
- Je n'ai à aucun moment demandé
de prioriser le dossier de
monsieur Mohamed Sifaoui et je
n'avais aucune raison de demander
à prioriser son dossier.
- Des explications qui n'ont guère
convaincu le président de la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale.
- Je crois qu'elle n'était accusée
de rien et qu'elle était là pour
répondre à nos questions de la
manière la plus précise qui soit.
Malheureusement, sur beaucoup de
sujets, on a plus senti de la
défense que réellement une
présentation claire des faits.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous étiez
l'un des sénateurs qui avaient
demandé la création de cette
commission d'enquête.
On a vu que Marlène Schiappa
s'était un peu défaussée de ses
responsabilités dans les
dysfonctionnements de la gestion
et de la mise en place de ce Fonds
Marianne.
Ca vous étonne, cette stratégie?
- Rachid Temal: C'est assez
surprenant.
Quand on est ministre, on a un
cabinet, on doit être responsable.
Le porte-parole du gouvernement
l'a dit à la sortie du Conseil des
ministres.
Lors de ces auditions, je souhaite
d'abord saluer le travail du
Sénat, mais je voudrais revenir
aussi sur les deux préfets qui ont
été auditionnés.
Il y avait notamment celui qui
était directeur du cabinet de
madame Schiappa.
Je pense que les deux ont été
assez honnêtes.
Ils ont dit à la fois que ce
qu'ils avaient fait, et le préfet
l'a aussi dit aussi, qu'il y avait
une forme de pression politique,
une forme de commande politique
qui ne répondait pas aux canons
habituels de travail et de
sérieux.
Je crois que Marlène Schiappa ne
répondait pas aux questions de la
commission, mais elle
s'interrogeait sur d'autres
éléments.
Elle répondait d'abord au parquet
financier.
Elle était ministre, elle dit
qu'elle n'était au courant de
rien.
Elle avait le choix entre assumer
sa responsabilité ou passer pour
quelqu'un d'assez léger dans la
gestion d'un ministère.
Ca nous inquiète sur cette
gestion.
- Kathia Gilder: Marlène Schiappa
a dit plusieurs fois qu'elle ne
savait pas.
Est-ce que c'est normal qu'un
ministre ne sache pas ce qu'il se
passe dans son propre cabinet?
- Rachid Temal: Moi-même, j'ai été
collaborateur de cabinet, vous en
référez à votre ministre.
De fait, le ministre ou le maire
doit assumer la responsabilité de
l'administration de son cabinet.
Par ailleurs, le directeur de
cabinet a indiqué que sur
l'association SOS Racisme, la
ministre avait dit non.
Tout cela est vrai.
Il a été indiqué qu'il y avait eu
des échanges entre Mohamed Sifaoui
et Marlène Schiappa.
Elle s'est totalement défaussée.
Et encore, c'est pour être poli.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous diriez quoi?
- Rachid Temal: Je prône une forme
d'irresponsabilité.
Ca a été le crash d'une ministre.
Soit elle n'assume pas ses
responsabilités, soit elle n'était
pas ministre.
- Kathia Gilder: Elle ne peut donc
pas rester durablement à son
poste?
- Rachid Temal: Je ne suis pas de
ceux qui appellent les ministres à
démissionner.
Elle a été nommée.
Si le président de la République
estime qu'elle peut rester, c'est
son souci à lui, avec tout ce que
cela suppose.
S'il souhaite s'en séparer, c'est
aussi sa responsabilité.
Il faut saluer le travail des
journalistes qui ont mis en
exergue toute cette affaire.
D'ici le 13 juillet, le président
remettra le rapport.
Le Sénat aura à tirer les
conséquences de tout cela.
On n'est pas la justice.
On essaie de voir ce qu'il s'est
réellement passé.
On veut aussi faire des
préconisations pour éviter
d'autres situations de cette
nature.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
vous diriez que Marlène Schiappa
est affaiblie politiquement?
- Rachid Temal: Je n'ai pas le
sentiment que jusque-là, ce soit
une personne structurante du
gouvernement.
Ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui
structure le débat politique.
Il fut un temps où elle a même été
expulsée du gouvernement avant de
revenir par la petite porte.
C'est la responsabilité du
gouvernement de choisir qui doit
rester.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que vous
estimez que Mohamed Sifaoui a eu
un traitement privilégié sans
avoir de meilleures compétences
que d'autres acteurs du monde
associatif?
Que retenez-vous de cette
audition?
- Rachid Temal: Je ne veux pas
aller sur la forme, mais plutôt
sur le fond.
Il a dit clairement qu'il avait
été approché par Marlène Schiappa
et son cabinet pour entrer dans
l'appel à projets.
Les choses sont claires.
Il a expliqué ce qu'il pouvait
faire.
On lui a dit très vite qu'il n'y
aurait pas de suite.
Tout ça s'est arrêté.
Mais pourquoi ce fonds?
Vous avez en France des milliers
d'associations, pour ne pas dire
plus, qui bossent au quotidien sur
des choses similaires.
Pourquoi ce fonds
particulièrement?
Il y a des gens bénévoles qui font
ça au quotidien en plus de leur
travail.
Là, on donne le sentiment qu'il y
a du tripatouillage, alors que des
millions de Français sont dans des
associations et travaillent très
bien.
Quand ces personnes voient ce
scandale, je comprends qu'elles
soient écoeurées.
- Alexandre Poussart: Ca risque de
jeter le discrédit, effectivement,
sur les associations en général.
- Rachid Temal: Je souhaite leur
rendre hommage ici.
Il faut que les Français
comprennent que les associations
bossent aujourd'hui sur le terrain
et qu'elles n'ont pas attendu le
Fonds Marianne et Marlène Schiappa
pour travailler.
C'est après l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty que ce fonds a été créé.
Il a été tué dans mon département.
C'est un drame qui aurait dû
ressouder la nation.
Je ne sais pas si ce sont des
barbouzeries, mais je souhaite
rendre hommage aux gens qui
s'investissent vraiment dans les
associations.
Je salue le fait que nous ayons
une commission d'enquête au Sénat
qui a conduit à cette enquête.
Je salue les millions de Français
qui sont dans des associations qui
ne sont pas de cette nature.
- Kathia Gilder: On va parler de
l'actualité à l'Assemblée
nationale.
Les déserts médicaux étaient à
l'ordre du jour.
Il y a une proposition de loi pour
améliorer l'accès aux soins sur le
territoire français.
Un amendement a été ajouté au
texte pour proposer de réguler la
liberté d'installation des
médecins.
Un amendement rejeté, malgré un
soutien transpartisan.
- La loi ne touchera pas à la
liberté d'installation des
médecins.
Des députés issus de neuf groupes
politiques, parfois même du camp
politique présidentiel, ont voulu
amender une proposition de loi
d'un député Horizons.
Pour lutter contre les déserts
médicaux, certains élus veulent
limiter l'arrivée des médecins
dans des zones bien pourvues, dans
l'espoir qu'ils aillent là où il
en manque.
- Nous disons à nos médecins de ne
plus aller s'installer là où les
besoins de soins sont déjà
pourvus.
Il faut aller s'installer où ils
veulent, ailleurs, là où les
besoins de santé ne sont pas
pourvus, là où les patients les
attendent.
- Ce n'est pas une régulation
drastique.
Ce n'est pas de la coercition.
Il y a une liberté totale qui
reste sur 93% du territoire
français.
- Depuis des années, la France
cherche la formule magique contre
les déserts médicaux, mais pour le
gouvernement et l'état-major du
groupe Renaissance, ce serait
encore pire.
- Seuls 5000 médecins se sont
installés en libéral depuis 10
ans.
Si vous essayez de les contraindre
plus, ils s'installeront encore
moins.
- Le ministre de la Santé a aussi
mis en garde contre un mauvais
signal envoyé aux médecins.
- Cet amendement serait une perte
durable de la confiance des
professionnels de santé.
Comment imaginez-vous engager
cette grande réforme du système de
santé sans la confiance des
professionnels?
- L'Assemblée a voté contre
l'amendement de ce député.
Il promet de continuer le combat.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a eu quand
même cette démarche transpartisane
pour faire aboutir cette loi et
permettre plus de régulation dans
l'installation des médecins, selon
l'intensité des offres de soins.
Ca n'a pas abouti.
Est-ce que vous le regrettez?
- Rachid Temal: Bien sûr, je le
regrette.
Je salue cette proposition de mon
collègue socialiste.
Quel est le problème, aujourd'hui?
On parle de la liberté des
médecins, à juste titre, mais il y
a aussi la liberté des Français de
pouvoir se faire soigner.
- Kathia Gilder: Ca veut dire que
la liberté de l'installation des
médecins est plus importante que
l'égalité de l'offre de soins?
- Rachid Temal: Pour ceux qui ont
voté contre l'amendement, oui.
Il y a la liberté des médecins,
mais il y a aussi la liberté des
Français de pouvoir se faire
soigner.
Les déserts médicaux, je vois bien
qu'il y en a le même nombre dans
mon département de l'Oise.
Une maison de santé a été créée à
Cergy-Pontoise, mais il n'y a
toujours pas de généralistes.
Il y a plus de 700 personnes qui
sont inscrites, parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'offre de soins.
On oublie souvent la question de
la tarification.
Quand vous êtes conventionné, il y
a un double système.
On oublie souvent cette partie-là.
Aujourd'hui, dans 93% du
territoire national, il n'y a pas
de sujet.
Le sujet est porté sur 7%.
On demande un régime dérogatoire
qui permette que la liberté de se
soigner soit permise.
C'est aussi simple que ça.
Je ne vois pas pourquoi les
médecins n'auraient pas de
contrainte pendant un an ou deux.
Ils pourraient avoir la liberté de
rentrer dans les 7% qui sont
aujourd'hui pénalisés.
C'est aujourd'hui un vrai drame
tous les territoires.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
ça veut dire que cet amendement va
être déposé une nouvelle fois?
- Rachid Temal: Pour être
transparent, nous avons aussi des
débats en notre sein.
Je fais partie de ceux qui veulent
être plus dynamiques.
Je crois qu'on a déjà beaucoup
débattu sur ce sujet.
Ca a déjà été fait.
Le ministre dit qu'il faut
attendre un peu qu'il y ait plus
de médecins formés.
Ca prend 10 ans pour former un
médecin.
Les Françaises et les Français
devront donc attendre 10 ans pour
aller voir le médecin.
Il faut trouver des médecins,
quand on les trouve, mais il faut
prendre en compte le coût du
médecin, et quand il n'y a pas de
médecin, on va à l'hôpital.
On arrive alors à la crise de
l'hôpital avec les conséquences
que l'on connaît.
On ne peut pas dire aux Français
que l'hôpital explose et qu'il
faut attendre 10 ans.
Je pense que la macronie fait
preuve encore une fois d'un manque
de réactivité.
- Kathia Gilder: François Braun
s'est félicité à l'issue des
débats en disant que la démocratie
parlementaire avait gagné.
Est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement envoie un mauvais
signal en ayant refusé cet
amendement?
- Rachid Temal: Je condamne la
position du ministre.
Il devait régler les problèmes de
l'hôpital et des médicaments, mais
rien n'est réglé.
Sur la capacité à réduire les
déserts médicaux, il n'y arrive
pas non plus.
C'est un échec total.
J'ai cru comprendre qu'il serait
lui-même sur la sellette.
Ce gouvernement adore utiliser des
mots comme "historique", mais la
réalité, ce n'est pas grand-chose.
Ils arrivent toujours à pénaliser
les plus pauvres.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous êtes
aussi vice-président de la
commission des Affaires étrangères
de la Défense et des Armées du
Sénat.
Cette commission a modifié le
projet de loi de programmation
militaire avant son examen dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat fin juin.
Ce projet de loi à 413 milliards
d'euros.
La commission du Sénat a décidé
d'accélérer cette hausse
budgétaire dès les premières
années de cette période,
2024-2030.
Voici le président de la
commission.
- On laisse au nouveau président
de la République
de décider en 2027.
Nous avons proposé un amendement
qui glisse cette somme
considérable et qui va permettre
de dépenser 3,6 milliards au lieu
de 3 milliards tout en restant
dans la même enveloppe.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le
gouvernement augmente
considérablement le moyen des
armées, mais en concentrant cette
hausse après 2027 pour ne pas
mettre dans le rouge les finances
publiques.
C'était la bonne stratégie?
- Rachid Temal: Actuellement, nous
sommes dans une loi de
programmation militaire.
Le gouvernement avait déjà fait le
coup de l'après-présidentielle.
Nous, les socialistes, nous avons
fait le choix au Sénat de bonifier
cette loi de programmation
militaire.
Nous l'avons fait en commission
avec le président Christian
Cambon.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous n'avez pas
la même loi de programmation
militaire?
Vous la bonifiez comment?
- Rachid Temal: Nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une loi où le
gouvernement refuse de faire le
bilan.
C'est surprenant.
Le gouvernement refuse d'avoir une
vision de perspectives.
Nous avons d'abord travaillé sur
cette question.
Nous avons aussi communiqué
beaucoup sur les 413 milliards
d'euros.
Comme il y a 2024 et 2025 qui sont
sur cette loi, il faut enlever 97
milliards.
Je vous donne les chiffres.
Je ne les invente pas.
Si vous prenez la loi de
programmation actuelle, elle va
jusqu'en 2025.
- Alexandre Poussart: C'est
l'enveloppe qui a déjà été votée.
- Rachid Temal: Il faut compter
entre 30 et 50 milliards d'euros
d'inflation.
Vous prenez ça et vous retirez
413.
Je ne tiens pas compte des 100
milliards déjà dans le chargeur et
toujours pas payés par l'Etat.
Il faut avoir un peu de modestie
dans cette affaire.
C'est vrai qu'on met de l'argent,
mais ce n'est pas historique.
L'autre sujet, c'est qu'il y a un
certain nombre de défis, notamment
la guerre en Ukraine, ce qui se
passe dans le Pacifique ou en
Afrique.
Quels sont les risques?
Quels sont les types de menaces
potentielles?
A partir de là, on peut améliorer
la loi.
Nous avons posé un article pour
dire quel était l'objectif de la
défense.
Plutôt que de mettre l'argent sur
la fin de la loi de programmation,
il faut le mettre dès aujourd'hui
pour lancer des programmes.
Tout cela coûte de l'argent.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est une bonne
idée de construire un nouveau
porte-avions?
Vous dites que c'est bien?
- Rachid Temal: Nous sommes
favorables à un porte-avions.
Nous savons que le
Charles-de-Gaulle va arriver en
fin de course.
C'est Gilbert Roger qui a déposé
un amendement.
On demande aussi une capacité de
maintenir en l'état le
porte-avions Charles-de-Gaulle
pour que le nouveau porte-avions
puisse être déployé plus loin.
Nous avons proposé des choses
comme ça.
Nous avons aussi proposé des
amendements pour améliorer la vie
concrète des troupes.
Les socialistes ont amené beaucoup
de choses.
- Kathia Gilder: Si vous le voulez
bien, on va jeter un oeil à
l'agenda à venir.
- Alexandre Poussart: Mardi, les
sénateurs entameront l'examen du
projet de loi industrie verte, un
texte censé décarboner notre
industrie.
Mercredi, Olivier Dussopt sera
auditionné sur son projet de loi
pour le plein emploi, un texte qui
prévoit de conditionner le
versement du RSA à une activité de
15 à 20h par semaine.
- Kathia Gilder: Olivier Dussopt
sera à l'Assemblée nationale dès
lundi.
Il sera auditionné sur le projet
de loi sur le partage de la valeur
issu d'un accord entre les
partenaires sociaux, avec pour but
de mieux partager les bénéfices
des entreprises.
Mardi, les députés vont réexaminer
la proposition de loi pour le
plafonnement des loyers après
l'échec des discussions avec le
Sénat.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va finir
cette émission par quelques
questions politiques.
On voit que le gouvernement Borne
s'active avec de nombreux textes.
Est-ce que cela peut lui donner un
nouveau souffle politique après la
séquence de la réforme des
retraites et lui éviter peut-être
un futur remaniement?
- Rachid Temal: C'est le président
de la République qui a parlé des
100 jours.
C'est lui qui a menacé son propre
gouvernement.
Le problème vient de la macronie
en elle-même.
Le problème n'est pas de savoir si
Elisabeth Borne va rester ou pas.
Il ne vous a pas échappé qu'à
l'Assemblée, la représentation du
gouvernement, elle est à majorité
relative.
Le problème est toujours le même.
Rien n'a changé depuis juin 2022.
- Kathia Gilder: La méthode texte
par texte, vous n'y croyez pas?
- Rachid Temal: A-t-elle marché
depuis un an?
- Alexandre Poussart: Il y a quand
même des textes qui passent.
- Rachid Temal: Vous avez aussi
des textes qui ne passent pas.
Pour le budget, il y a eu pas
moins de 15 ou 17 49.3.
Il y a un problème de majorité
structurelle à l'Assemblée.
On ne peut pas avoir un
gouvernement qui nous dit
"Peut-être bien que oui, peut-être
bien que non."
Tout le monde court après
l'extrême droite, mais sur le
texte de l'immigration, ils le
mettent, ils le retirent...
Je pourrais continuer comme ça
avec d'autres exemples.
Nous considérons qu'à ce stade, il
y a un problème de majorité
fiable, mais il faut que monsieur
Macron comprenne le résultat des
élections de juin 2022.
Ils n'ont pas compris que les
Français ne leur ont pas donné de
majorité absolue en juin 2022.
- Alexandre Poussart: Il y aura
des élections cette année, les
élections sénatoriales, le 24
septembre.
Dans cette campagne, il y a des
tensions au sein du Parti
Socialiste, notamment à Paris.
Le patron du PS refuse de valider
la liste des candidats socialistes
aux sénatoriales à Paris.
Il dit que cette liste
contiendrait uniquement des
candidats proches d'Anne Hidalgo
qui est hostile à la NUPES.
Est-ce que ce ne sont pas les
divisions du Parti Socialiste qui
rejaillissent?
- Rachid Temal: Je ne crois pas.
Il n'y a aucun endroit en France
où il y a une liste du PS.
La vraie lecture, ce n'est pas ça.
Il reste deux ou trois fédérations
où il y a des discussions.
Tout le reste a été adopté par le
bureau national.
N'inventons pas des histoires où
il n'y en a pas.
Tous les socialistes sont
favorables à ce qu'il y ait un
accord avec le Parti Communiste ou
avec les Verts.
Les socialistes sont rassemblés.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce qu'il
faut changer d'approche sur Paris?
- Rachid Temal: Il faut penser à
ce qu'il se passe ailleurs aussi.
Aujourd'hui, il y a un désaccord
entre la liste adoptée par les
militants parisiens et la vision
qu'Olivier Faure en a.
Il y aura sûrement des changements
dans les 10 ou 15 jours qui
viennent.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce qu'il y
aura une vraie union de la gauche
lors de ces sénatoriales?
- Rachid Temal: Je vous ai parlé
d'accords.
Il y a localement des discussions.
On n'a jamais eu des accords
parfaits partout.
Nous, on veut passer jusqu'à 100
parlementaires de gauche au Sénat.
- Kathia Gilder: Merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA